welcome back to another episode of from
the point by your favorite Point brought
to you by Sprite the clear
favorite I'm also here again my brother
Winston you're too far bro I ain't gonna
lie little hard for little far for
handshake but uh a little banged up now
man how you doing man another week
another episode another month another
episode we back here with Bleacher
Report how you feel yes it's uh it's a
great great day to be back uh got some
stuff to talk about that's cool been
been a great month though man a lot of
mix in the Sports World I was watching
the NFL playoffs man shout out to CJ
strad and Jordan love man balling
balling balling that ain't the word it's
like hooping like overdoing it man ho
both are going crazy hooping who you got
who you got in the Super Bowl ah Super
Bowl lot of football left lot of
football left I I don't want to doubt
Lamar this may be the year that he just
erases all the doubt of everybody and
I'm pulling for him so I want Lamar to
win one
um so I think I'm gonna go with them on
that
side uh man I don't
know I don't know man it's going to be
them it's gonna
be who you
got I got Baltimore winning it all I I
think I think Baltimore just because
they're playing really really good
football right now I think like you said
Lamar has been playing excellent I think
they're receiving core I'm so happy to
see Odell ball in Odell hooping he's
he's hooping um and then on the opposite
side I mean listen Detroit's out here
balling right now but the 49ers going
that's that's the only other team I
think can can win at all CU they got
yeah their defense is crazy their
defense is crazy they got Christian
mcaffrey they have um George K from
Oklahoma George KD from Norman Oklahoma
shout out Norman out Norman Norman High
um I mean you got Brock pie uh you got
you got got some got some killers on
offense too yeah NFL isn't the only the
only uh Sports you know that we've had
going on MLK was a really big day for
hoops man um talk about the importance
that it was playing on MLK and uh I mean
it's it was an honor honor to uh play
onl day uh it always is especially here
in Atlanta uh I mean just knowing the
history I mean that he brought not only
to the I mean the African-American uh
people I mean just the city of Atlanta
like I mean he has family he has family
that still lives here so to be able to
put on that Jersey and play on this day
uh in in this city is it means something
to me so it's it's always an honor to be
able to represent him on on a on a
special day for sure absolutely it's
it's great to honor his memory honor his
family's Legacy glad you guys were able
to get the win on MLK Day listen I don't
know of many people that scored their
scored their 10,000th point and then
pull up and record a podcast directly
after so man congratulations on your
10,000 Point um seriously though you
became the fastest player in NBA history
to reach 10,000 points 35,000 assists
and 1,000 three-pointers made you did it
in 390 games bro that's is pretty fast
pry cool getting into those stats man
you gonna be able to keep this up your
whole career I mean that's the plan I
don't I don't doubt it I mean obviously
age is going to um make it tougher as I
get older but uh right now I feel good I
mean obviously I'm not old so I'm just
continuing to play the way I've always
been playing so it's definitely a
blessing to be able to reach 10,000
points and all these assists but I mean
I obviously couldn't do it without my
teammates like I mean getting me the
ball having space on the floor for me to
create for myself like uh so it's not
anytime you get an achievement or reward
individually it's never especially in a
sport that we play in an individual and
award so U my teammates helped me a lot
throughout these years and uh to help me
get where I am right now yeah I'm on
Pace for that too did you know that oh
you are that same stat line except uh
mine is in my men's league and I think
I'm on Pace to be the youngest in my
men's league by about 40 years to get
there so if I if I hit if I hit that
Mark by about age 57 and a half I'll be
good I'll be good money I think you'll
be on the right path with the 10,000th
point actually you officially qualify
for the NBA's alltime points per game
leaderboard in their in their career so
basically um taking everybody's career
averages and and who who has the highest
uh of that career average you actually
are 13th on that list some of the greats
on that list include Will Chamberlain
Michael Jordan man what what does it
feel like to be on that list with some
of those greats man it's an it's a I
mean unreal feeling it's an I mean an
honor to be mentioned with those type of
guys it's it's crazy um those are guys
that I've lifted up to and uh I mean
even guys that I didn't necessar get to
watch play I know who they were and I
know the impact that they had on the
game before I was even thought of so uh
I definitely appreciate um being on
those types of list because I know I
mean it's only greats ahead of me and
even around me so um you can only
appreciate being on those types of list
and appreciate the teammates and the
people that helped you be on that type
of list too so I know I couldn't do it
by myself all the dominoes fell
yesterday it seems like in terms of
playing on such an important day in
history with honoring MLK's Legacy you
hitting such an amazing um career
statline for you um you actually gave
your jersey to a fan yesterday um and I
didn't get to see the sign by any chance
but I remember we were we were talking
last night and talking about he just he
held up this sign that I just I couldn't
couldn't resist man I had to give him my
jersey yeah such a dope video no yeah it
was cool I uh a lot of people hit me um
even my dad uh hit me asked me if I I
kept the Jersey after the game and uh
thankfully my equipment manager at half
time grabbed the Jersey cuz I guess I
mean I scored I needed like one point in
the second half or something I had no
idea before the game I was close to this
and and all that but uh so the equipment
manager took my jersey at at halftime
and and just kept it because he knew I
was going to want to keep my jersey and
probably give give one away after the
game so um he kept that Jersey and I
think I needed one point in the second
half and did it and after the game I
gave away that but I definitely kept the
the jersey that I had in the first half
so uh yeah no but that I saw a sign and
it was it was really cool and it's like
they had just came from somewhere or it
was a birthday celebration so I wanted
to give him give him something
definitely made definitely made that
kids night for sure you played against
the Spurs last night Victor wiim minyama
ton of hype around him what was it like
I know this your second time playing him
this year but just to be able to share
the court with him get to get to see
some of his game and and what that's
been about how would you say as a as a
peer you're most excited for him to
continue to grow his game and and what's
it like sharing the floor with him I
mean he's going to be a beast in this
league uh I mean as long as he can play
he his presence on the floor alone is is
impactful and I mean just on defense
offense he can create for other people
he just disrupts people on on defense so
he can do pretty much everything and
it's everything that everybody's been
saying about him and uh you can tell
he's humble he he he competes he wants
to work hard so uh he has all the
intangibles to be I mean the best player
ever um it's just I mean the accolades
and team accolades as his career goes on
is what's going to determine that so uh
he definitely has a tools though you
guys have both trained with Tim Martin a
trainer who unfortunately I'm not cold
enough to train with um Tim you know if
you're watching this man definitely hit
me up for some training sessions I still
need it to dominate my men's league but
um have you ever trained with wimy
before I actually don't know this no I
you Haven no I have there been any
instances where Tim is like dude like
before he got drafted I'll say like
because I know you and Tim are super
close that Tim was like because
obviously Victor works out with him like
oh man like be on the lookout cuz this
dude is he's for real yeah no I had I've
been working with Tim since I was in
high school um I mean we work out once
or twice a year I go down to Dallas I go
down on Christmas uh trained with him
and some other guys I've trained with
him in the summertime I go down there
and uh just spend to a weekend or two in
Dallas and uh just train with him just
spend some time with him um and he would
always tell me how he was going back and
forth to France to work with this young
kid who's going to be the next Prodigy
this next up and cominging thing and um
he was always telling me about him and
as Victor was obviously getting older
the the world started knowing more and
more about him and um I just had I mean
I had heard about him I didn't know what
he was going to be and seeing him now I
can tell the reason I mean I know Tim is
probably not the only person I bet Tim
will tell you himself that he's not the
only person that put Victor in these
situations or Gave Victor all these
tools but he's definitely one of these
guys and so just seeing Victor play for
the first time just as a high school kid
and then now or I mean being overseas
and then now coming over here you can
tell that some of the things that Tim
puts in his workouts and his training
sessions that Victor has in this game
and I mean Tim is a guard so just having
guard likee skills and mindset when
you're 74 75 like it's hard to stop so
um but no Tim Tim had told me about him
um a long time ago before uh I mean a
lot of people over here really knew
about him because he was going over
there training him I know Tim's some of
his workouts are notorious for having
these crazy intensive drills there was a
there was a clip obviously we were still
going to school at the time I didn't
even know you did this but it surfaced
probably like six months ago where he
would take the Rock and he would throw
it from under the goal and you'd have to
go run get it catch and shoot run get it
catch and shoot it was going on for like
90 seconds I think he made like 20
something in a row um I also heard that
Tim actually
teaches and has taught folks how to like
properly nutmeg people and um you
obviously have some Notorious nutmegs
now it looks like we got seven4 dudes in
the league nutmegging dudes I mean like
is this like does he really teach people
like how to how to Nutmeg I I don't know
about the nut Megan part he may be
teaching other people now he ain't teach
me how to do that uh but he he
definitely you can teach people out to
do that I wouldn't be surprised if he
does um I mean he teaches he teaches a
lot of in work in his workouts about
conditioning and doing keeping your feet
moving with with the ball moving at the
same time like never um never let a
Defender like guess your next move and
things like that so uh no he he's
definitely one of the best trainers out
here for sure so who who taught you you
just practice on like you know some
dummies to yeah just practice I mean
messing around and then getting playing
in Oklahoma you can you can practice
sometimes okay you practice sometimes in
games um there was a I think you
commented on yeah I think it was a
Bleacher Report post but there was that
clip where Victor actually like jumped
up in the air like one of his teammates
be somebody off the dribble and like had
a lob opportunity for him and I think
you comment is like man this is a easy
lob um but talk about what it would be
like to play with somebody it could be
him or it could be somebody else in the
league cuz you've played with a a couple
guys before where they have incredible
athleticism and all that just reading
lobs just in general I think it would I
think it would be great for you to talk
about what that's like to read a lob
actually because people don't understand
like how difficult that is to throw lobs
just in general you're obviously one of
the most proficient in the league so
yeah like how would you read plays where
you would have to throw a lob and um I I
think what I
mean the the part about throwing a lob
is is really just having confidence in
your big too and knowing
that um he's going to go jump and get it
like I feel like I I give my big so much
confidence as far as
like if they set a screen they get
behind their man because I'm I feel like
if I get into the paint his man's going
to worry about me so if they don't worry
about me I'm going to be shooting
floaters to death and uh just getting
good shots in the paint and So
eventually they're always going to get
good looks because a team is not just
going to let um let me do that all game
so they're eventually going to step up
and so uh I really just tell our bigs
just just keep rolling keep rolling keep
setting screens and every big I really
played with from Dwayne deadmond Alex
Lynn I mean John CC like I mean Big O
like they've all they all know how to
set screens and they all bring different
attributes to the game so it's it's just
about knowing my big strengths and uh
thankfully I've been playing with who
can who can who can jump a little bit
and go catch my lives and so it's more
about just feeding them and just knowing
when and when and and how to give it to
him for sure absolutely um pivot here
but uh we're about a month away from
Allstar can't believe the season's
already going by this fast um we're
expected to have the third and final fan
Returns come out this
week let's actually take a look um for
these the second returns um where those
are at
said that's the West it's the West we
got for sure guard wise that's going to
be three that's
locks do you agree with those so far
yeah I mean it's going to
be I mean it's LeBron yish KD like it's
Lucas you can't really argue with this
it's more about the fans it's like what
do the fans want to see it's an allstar
game so like no matter how bad the
Warriors are doing right now they you
want to see Steph Curry play want see
the best people play absolutely yeah I
agree with it Shay could be up there
higher than Steph okay here's the
East yeah I agree with it too I think
you said it best honestly the All-Star
game is about seeing the best
players play with each other on the
court I think yeah I I don't I don't
know how you could disagree with this I
think the All-Star thing like the
allstar it's about it's about the the
fans like I mean it's not about anybody
else it's about the fans and so I I I
see why they give the fans their own
vote and really a big big part of the
reason why guys are starters um so no
it's it's a it's a fan it's a fan award
it's a fan vote it's for the fans like
you don't go to the players go to
Allstar for the fans like we don't we
don't go there for us for real we go
there for the fans for our families and
for the environment to to bring
everybody with us to have fun for the
weekend celebrate I mean the the work we
put in in the first half of the season
and understanding the second half is
just right around the corner so it's
just uh yeah I think it's just for the
fans so I think the the returns are
where they should be yeah one point 1.4
that that's a lot of that's a lot of
people voting for for Trey young second
time around it's a bless it's a blessing
for sure I I feel like a lot of my fans
know if if I don't get voted in it's
gonna be tough for me to to get in maybe
this year is different but in the past
and previous years uh if I didn't get in
as a as a as a starter I haven't really
ever got in as a as a reserve so maybe
that's why they're voting for me what
does a third selection mean to you in
terms of your legacy in terms of I think
you said it best too though is like you
really go up there to put on a show as
to all those guys and how but what I
mean what does the third selection mean
to you though uh I mean it mean a lot to
me it mean um the work I've put in is
being paid off and um obviously I know I
still have more work to do because what
I want to do is win a championship it's
not to be an Allstar and um to be
nothing like that but I mean being an
Allstar you can't take that for granted
and I mean not everybody is is blessed
with the opportunity to be all stars
even really good players have never had
the chance to be an Allstar so I can
never just sit up here and take that for
granted um but at the same time I have
bigger goals and bigger dreams that I
want to I achieve and after being
snubbed a couple times I feel like the
allstar game is is a different Outlook
in my eyes than maybe to somebody else
so uh that's how I look at it and for me
I would rather now I'd rather see my boy
bogy being the Three-Point Contest and
uh that would make my Allstar Weekend
really cool that's awesome I want to
play a little little game with you um
since we're talking about Allstar
Weekend uh I want you to take these
three challenges and build what you
think would be the best Saturday night
basically what I want you to do is name
a name a player or group of players that
you would like to see participate in
these three things okay first is the
skills
challenge so it's just right now or all
time or I think I think all time okay
all all time they're do all time uh
they're gonna do all time
skills first person that comes to mind
is dwade D way always had I think he won
a couple if I don't if I haven't forgot
uh Steve NZ I'm going put him in there
them two and then I'mma go two
more uh dang this is a tough one skills
competition um I'm G put me in the
skills all the time uh I feel like I got
cheated Jason hit that halfcourt shot of
me I should have me a skills
Championship um but us three and then
I'll put
in Chris paw that's good list I think
I'm going I think I'm going Magic
Johnson
Steve Nash Chris
Paul and I think I'm going throw Oscar
Oscar in there too Oscar Robertson okay
that's proba that's probably my four
just so you can see him because you Ain
never really get to see him yeah exactly
I I really I'm we were too young to
watch Magic other than highlights too so
I think I think that would bepe be yeah
uh Three-Point Contest three-point got
to put Steph got to
put Steph is in there I'mma put Ray
Allen in there MH I'mma put
um Reggie Miller sniper in there I'mma
put for the last one dang this is so
tough I'mma
put I'm GNA go Chris Mullen great list
Lefty I agree with you I my personal
preference would be the first three so
Steph Reggie and Ray Allen I'm I'm also
throwing in paa sakovich okay okay okay
shout out Paia man I'm a huge Paia I'm a
huge Paia fan uh last is Dunk Contest
dun contest
okay like this one's gonna be a little
bit more easier um I'mma put the uh put
Vince
Carter one I'm go put Zack
LaVine one B
to that dude got bounce
uh man I'm going give gor some love cuz
he even though he ain't got love for
winning one he could have won one IM
Ander Jones that was a battle and then
I'mma go Human Highlight with Dominique
greaty list yeah I think I'm
going personally I I think I'm going
Gerald Green Gerald Green had bounce
crazy I I think you gotta go Vince
Carter Vince Carter uh I I would just
the inner faning I would love to see
Lebron in a in a dunk contest yeah but
he no he ain't tired of seeing that
tired I I he yeah just my yeah we know
he would win one Braun and then I think
my fourth guy in the dunk
contest probably gonna go
Kobe I'm I'm g go and Kobe froby too
like I man that would
be yeah yeah those are my four you may
have won are we gonna see you in the D
contest come on man nice question
um so on uh on a little bit more focus
on the season um you guys are currently
11th in the East you guys are looking to
make a big jump before Allstar and then
obviously post Allstar but you guys have
been in the situation before um in 2021
you were 16 and 20 before the All-Star
Break um and then finished the season 25
and
11 what was that moment in
2021 that you look back on there like
okay I very clearly see a switch in our
team in our locker room and what are you
looking forward
to to implementing that again to seeing
that switch to making that improvement
post Allstar and eventually making a run
for the playoffs well first I I don't
even it's hard to really compare years
like because every team every year is
something different every year brings
something new and something a different
Challenge and so that year was a
different challenge that was brought to
us and something happened we made a
change and then it was it was out of
there and we were able to go on a run
and turn the season around I mean for me
I don't necessarily know I mean what the
the challenge is and point a finger on
the challenge what it is for us right
now um but for me I just hope that like
whatever it is we can fix it and and go
about it the right way and then as the
season goes go on it all turns like like
it did for us a couple years ago but
it's hard to say
that we do what we did back then now and
expect the same result because this is a
totally different team a totally
different situation that brings new
challenges so you can't really do that
and so for me I I don't want to look at
it like that I just hope whatever
challenge that we have right now that
we're going through that we can find out
what it is and and figure it out and
then we'll make it we'll make it work
and make the and with those challenges I
think not I think it's very clear that
there's a lot of outside noise that goes
on you have beat Riders constantly on
the Hawks case you have Twitter and
social media so the 24-hour news cycle
as a professional but also a leader of a
team how important is it for you to be
able to block out the noise and also
make sure you're helping your entire
group and yourself play at a high level
perform and eventually win games I mean
it's important that you block out the
noise but um it's I mean you gonna hear
it it's not like we don't hear it's not
like we all aren't aware of what's being
said about each of us outside the locker
room um but that's where I feel like we
got to be better as far as just for each
other and I think we we have in certain
moments uh throughout games but just not
even worrying about that worry about
like our what we have going on right now
and um cuz we we can only control we can
control and in the NBA we can only
control so much and for us as players
like I think it's hard being in those
situations it's hard hearing your name
being talked about going somewhere else
and uh you could be moved here whenever
you could be in the middle of a game and
be traded I've been a part of teams
where that's happened and it it's not
easy I mean for us as a team we just
have to figure it out and just as this
is process is going I think what we've
been doing is being just Pros about it
and and guys have been Pros about the
situation and just um focus on what we
can control and that's just trying to
win games for for each other and playing
good because at the end of the day
you're always playing for I mean you're
always being watched um and so if you
continue to win that's going to that's
going to matter um before you leave so I
think it's just about making sure you're
a pro throughout the whole situation
with losses with sometimes frustration
uh can sometimes have there there's fan
frustration that comes with a struggling
team sometimes Stephen Clay actually had
two little bit differing opinions on
this um Steph said that I'm booing
myself it's not our job to give them or
it's our job to give them something to
cheer about and we haven't done that yet
clay took a little bit more of a
different approach and was like listen I
don't really care you supposed are you
supposed to lose sleep over it or or
what um what's your what's your reaction
to this and I know that you have your
fair share of experience with hearing
crowds boo yeah not saying at home but
just in general I think I know where
you're going to go with this but oh I
mean don't ever assume CU that's when
you make a ass out of you and me uh but
no uh I think for me I mean I know like
I I would
rather cuz to be honest I feel like we
haven't I've never been bued in Atlanta
until like last couple games and to be
honest with you like I feel like I'm on
more of the step approach as far as like
they should be buling us like but I feel
like that only comes with expectations
like I mean they they talking about in
Detroit they'll Boo and they talking
about s team because they lose 20
something games straight but they
weren't talking about that whenever they
lost 10 11 games because they didn't
really have expectations so the
expectations weren't there and so team
the fans don't necessarily care as much
and so when a fan base boo that just
shows how much they really care and how
much I mean they're they're mad that the
expectations aren't being met and so I
don't necessarily mind it I think it's
there's appropriate booos and then
there's not and I think in certain cases
where like us this year like us not
meeting certain expectations like we're
like we should be there can be moments
where you can be booed and so I think in
the same same breath with them they've
been Champion so uh they their
expectations are high and so um and
their fans are of them as well so I
think it's expected whenever uh the
expectations well said so you're saying
in response to that that there are a
culmination of things but really what
sets it over the top is expectations is
that you're expected to meet certain
expectations and you don't that's when
they're warranted yeah for sure got it
yeah that's that's what it is I've got a
new little segment uh shout out to our
producers that they help they helped us
craft this up but we're calling this new
segment Trey's
bag um we we've got some we've got some
questions from the from X and the
bleacher report app uh that would would
love love your response on um so first
one I have is do you like making a big
three at home or away
more
o victory at home or away I don't know
it's something about um something about
both of them something about both I
don't know I love I love making a big
three at home so we can all celebrate
all in the arena home home home's my
pick yeah what's your favorite game
winner of your
career favorite game winner of my
career
uh favorite game winner was
probably dang I can't I'm probably just
going to say the the latest one in TD
Garden and Celtics just cuz it was
against the best team I played against
in the playoffs and they just in that
arena is crazy so it was a a good one
that would be mine or the one where you
kind of like caught it on the on the
line the catch and made it when
Milwaukee was at home that one was great
that was crazy Atlanta went crazy
whenever you made whenever you made that
shot um the other the the last question
question I have is
Jaylen looks like he is a budding star
in the league he's really cementing
himself on the Hawks team how have you
personally helped him mature in his
game um I mean I think I'm a small piece
of his his maturity and his game I think
a lot of it is just him being able to be
on the court now and have the opport
opportunity to fail and and succeed like
when you are on the on the bench and
don't get to play you don't even get a
chance and uh I think now that he's
gotten more comfortable and now he's
gotten more in the rotation he's he's
able to show more what he can do and so
for me all I can really give him is
advice throughout the game stuff I see
things that I can I I see that I can
make the game easier for him and because
at the end of the day I need him just as
much as he needs me and uh I think just
us continuing to communicate okay with
each other is going to be important and
um no he's a hell of a player so I'm
just glad that people are finally
getting to see it but it was it was more
about him just being a to be on the
floor and uh just getting the
opportunity to play uh is what what was
holding him back yeah I think you and
Hawks fans uh around the country around
the world are just excited to see what
you guys can continue to build in
Atlanta so yeah that's great brother ice
thanks so much uh it's it's always a
pleasure man to get to record with you
um shout out to all the fans that have
been been watching us and thanks so much
to our presenting sponsor Sprite for
that crisp lemon lime taste it's a clear
favorite
obviously there we go another episode of
from the point by your favorite Point
see y'all again soon peace
[Music]
peace